hey guys Pete here this will be my recap
and review for better call Saul season 5
episode 6 Wexler beat Goodman talk about
an episode that has it all
we had big developments in both sides of
the story a reveal about a favorite
characters history an ice-breaking bad
character cameo and a very twisty ending
that i'm still reeling from quick
spoiler warning if you haven't watched
episode 6 yet this video will definitely
spoil it for you hit the subscribe
button
go watch Wexler V Goodman and then come
back to watch this video because there
is a lot to think about there's things
happening on the cartel side so let's
get that out of the way first personally
I haven't been a fan of mike's journey
back from the depths but that is what it
is and as this episode opens it's
confirmed that he is working at Gus's
side again they go together to meet with
nacho to find out what Lalo has been
planning Mike's presence is a surprise
to nacho because of the history they
share nacho tells them that Lalo is
using krazy-8 to give information to the
DEA his goal is to get the cartel to the
point where they think Gus isn't worth
the trouble leaving the Salamanca's to
have full control of things in the US he
plus it get Gus's dealers arrested on
the drug side and threatens to target
his legitimate businesses as well
Gus gives Victor orders to shake things
up and to protect their guys and then he
tells nacho from now on that he'll
report to Mike after he leaves not to
him Mike talk from their history nacho
knows that Mike hates the Salamanca
nacho makes the case that Gus is just as
bad or worse at first Mike brushes it
off saying he warned him in the past
that this kind of thing would happen and
after all nachos made his own choices
when nacho tells Mike that Gus
threatened his father's life it strikes
a chord innocent people paying the price
is something Mike knows way too much
about and he tells nacho they'll have a
conversation about the situation after
they deal with Lalo I mentioned in my
last video that I could see Mike going
full team Gus in exchange for nachos
freedom and after this exchange I feel
like that's where this might be heading
Mike decides to approach the Lalo
problem with a non-violent solution
which is reminiscent of his plan with
Tuco back in season 2 he slips into
private investigator
in hopes of putting the cops on to
Lalo's trail the whole situation that
travel wire seemed to go away too easily
and that's where Mike starts he visits a
librarian who we saw try to enter the
store while Lalo was in there watching
the video footage
Mike's able to lead her into remembering
Lala's car by showing her photos and
then he applies enough pressure to get
her to call the police and report what
she saw before he leaves he then slips
into his cop persona to get a report of
the hit and run Lalo got into while he
was trying to follow Mike onto the desk
of the investigating officer of the
travel wire case the Hanke adjacent
detective Tim Roberts who showed up in
seasons 2 & 4 Breaking Bad makes the
connection with the car I love this
handling of the phone call he was on and
the timing of how this report makes its
way to his desk knowing that the police
will be on the lookout for the car Mike
just pretends to be an officer and
passes off the location that nacho gives
him Lalo has stopped and surrounded and
has no choice but to give in
he thinks of going for his gun that he
has under a seat but realizes there's
too many cops and he's not gonna be able
to get away
this leaves things looking bad for the
Salamanca's and we can imagine that this
is going to open the door for Jimmy to
get involved while team Gus definitely
came out on top of this round I can't
imagine that Lala won't come up with a
plan to even the score what's really
nice about this though is seeing Mike
operate he's good at what he does and
it's fun to watch in the Jimmy and Kim's
side of things
first things first it's always good to
see the film students Jimmy shows them
an old Mesa bird a commercial it
features Kevin's dad and we also get to
see a young Kevin in that the video is
just sort of what you would expect and
they do a good job of showing us that
Jimmy has a very well-thought-out vision
without letting us know what it is he's
up to after learning that his initial
plan is too ambitious they set on using
a green screen in the nail salon after
hours the montage of them filming is fun
to watch as he directs the community
theater actors but the real payoff is
much later when we get to see the
finished product
after losing her cool with rich last
week and completely boggling our minds
with her decision-making this season Kim
seems to have come to her senses she
shows up to call things off the thing
that stood out to me here is that Kim
had the initial idea
but we see as she watches him through
the window that Jimmy has really hit his
stride in making this thing a reality
she can see that and it makes the
decision harder but she still decides
that she's made up her mind and she's
going to follow through in typical Kim
fashion she's figured out how to fix
things without jeopardizing her career
objectively it's the right decision and
it feels good to see her come around
Jimmy is disappointed but I think at
this point he's willing to let it go for
her he will change his mind later though
and that's where things get really
interesting Kim goes on to get things in
order telling Mesa Verde that Acker will
settle in apologizing to rich for her
outbursts all in all the crisis is
averted and the future's looking bright
over at swai curtain Coakley meanwhile
Saul Goodman gets an idea after turning
down a freebie from a couple of clients
who are sex workers as a reward for
helping them beat their charges to
continue his terrorizing of Howard he
sends the two women to harass him while
he's having lunch with cliff from Davis
and main everything about this is gold
it's fun but equal parts painful to
watch Howard squirm and it has to be
said that he doesn't actually deserve
this by offering Jimmy a job he's opened
himself up to public humiliation and
make no mistake Jimmy couldn't be more
pleased with the results
oh god I'm good he says and that sets
things in motion
to be fair Jimmy does hesitate for a
moment to consider what he's about to do
there's a slight hint and an internal
struggle going on but he's already had a
taste of the high while filming the
commercial and he knows his scam will
work I think that's really the important
part is that he has confidence that it's
going to play out just as he planned it
he makes a phone call to the
photographer and then there's no turning
back
better call Saul is famous for
delivering scenes that can only be
described as difficult to experience
Chuck's courtroom meltdown is just one
of many that comes to mind and Wexler V
Goodman delivers something that might
even be worse than that betraying Chuck
is one thing there were plenty of
dastardly deeds that you could look to
and say yeah he kind of deserves it
betraying Kim is something different
that's why Kurt and Coakley everyone is
assembled to put the mr. Acker case to
bed we see Kim sitting
there and there's a striking resemblance
to her face as she sees her plan coming
together to Jimmy's while he was filming
at the nail salon she made it back to
where she feels she's on the right side
of things and she's eager to move past
it we watched that look leave her face
as she realizes Jimmy's about to go
forward with his original plan in spite
of telling her that he would drop it we
witnessed the glory of Saul Goodman saw
the time as he reveals the fruits of his
labor before Kim can get Kevin and Paige
out of the room
Jimmy unleashes and the video is
hilarious it's balanced so expertly with
him working the room and complete
control as well it's outrageous it's
completely libelous the graphics the
community theater actors all of it is
just fantastic and of course it's not
even the big part of their plan that is
in fact a copyright infringement case
over the Mesa Verde logo remember Kim
saw the photo of this photo and she
realized that they used that to make the
logo while they bought the photograph
and paid for it that's not the same as
buying the rights to use it for their
corporate logo Jimmy had tracked down
the original photographer and is
dangling this idea of a year's long
battle in the courts over the rights to
this image this was the plan that Kim
had it worked exactly as they thought it
would and Saul Goodman has officially
put Mesa Verde in a position where they
can't just make it go away it really
feeds into Kevin's personality as well
he's fuming he says he's just going to
the bathroom but he chooses to call Saul
on the phone that leads to a great
back-and-forth out in the parking lot
where Jimmy has him exactly where he
wants him he negotiates things so that
everything goes his way Acker gets extra
money the photographer gets some money
Kevin will have to make public apologies
and of course I'm sure he'll get a nice
fee for the trouble this is where it is
really good you could see why Jimmy did
what he did you don't have to endorse it
you don't have to agree with it but you
can understand how he justified it to
himself and we see how that all plays
out when Kim
comes home later while the original plan
that they came up together worked and he
insulated Kim by not telling her what he
was going to do it's a complete betrayal
he made her into the sucker
he not only scammed Mesa Verde he
scammed his partner and for the first
time I think Kim truly understands that
he can't really help himself he's
incapable of changing his ways he didn't
do it to hurt her he doesn't want to
hurt her in any way he truly does care
for her but at the same time he can't
stop being who he is and that's not
necessarily compatible when you have a
trusting relationship with someone it
looks here that she reaches her breaking
point that she sees that her only choice
is to end this relationship
it's amazing the range of emotions I
experienced while I was watching him
betray her doing his thing in the
conference room with Mesa Verde trying
to bring her back at home to see his
side of things when it just isn't
possible and then seeing her make peace
with the decision that she has to make
it was incredible television just such a
great episode of TV and of course it
does not end there as it's playing out
as she's ending this and we feel like
we're seeing the end of their
relationship she ends the conversation
with the suggestion that maybe they
should get married
it was crazy like I did not know what to
think
I still don't I've read some great takes
on it the bottom line is that it's never
been a healthy relationship there's
always been an irrational 'ti to it
we've known that Kim would be better off
if Jimmy wasn't a part of her life she's
been in love with him just the same
I haven't mentioned the teaser yet the
flashback to her childhood and I think
that that's where the real parallel
comes into play in that we see that her
mother lets her down and more than that
she blames Kim as she's driving away she
says you never listened and we see that
Kim can draw the line there she walks
home at night in the cold
alone on the principle of it when it
comes to Jimmy she just hasn't been able
to do that on one side she's bounced
back from that painful childhood she has
a good career she's self-made she's
financially stable but she's in a
complicated relationship
loves Jimmy and there's no question that
he loves her she's invested a lot of
time she gets something out of it and
things like this are never easy and it's
always complicated and I am so curious
to see where things go from here I'm
still processing it I don't really know
I've seen a lot of people on reddit
thrown out this idea that it's a legal
move as far as confidentiality between
spouses like you can't be compelled to
testify against your spouse while that
might come into it later on down the
road and I think there's a chance that
that might be the case it's way more
complicated than that this isn't simply
her making a decision to marry Saul
because that will cover her ass where
you end up on this will probably be
influenced by your own relationships and
that's why it's such a good bit of
writing
there's no right explanation for why
people do the things that they do in
relationships but we care about both of
these characters and damn I didn't see
that coming so I could just ramble on
about this I've been sitting here
writing about it for a couple hours at
this point but this video is already
long so I'm gonna leave it there let me
know what you think in the comments not
only about her proposal at the end but
where you think things go from here and
let me know where you rank this as far
as Jimmy slash Saul's most shocking
betrayals as mentioned this was a really
solid episode there's so much going on
the execution was near flawless the
acting the directing the writing
everything is just hitting all the
performances are great all the time for
the most part but I just have to say
that racy Horne and Bob Odenkirk
together their scenes are just amazing
Rhea seehorn really has to be in Emmy
contention after the season as far as
I'm concerned watching her through the
betrayal and the way she delivered the
reality of the situation to Jimmy Jimmy
playing smoke on the water was a fun
callback to Marco and the end of season
1 we still have a ways to go in season 5
so it's a really good time to be a fan
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching I
will talk to you soon